and i consider myself a very organized
person
so if you look at my desktop you would
see that there is just a little a few
files some folders and some screenshots
around there
and there are things that i look at from
time to time from example screenshots
that i forget to delete after using them
but between
among those screenshots there is a very
special screenshot which you can sell as
an
nft which i don't care for but
this screenshot is one i took in 2019
from an answer in stack overflow
and it says
this
html5 specifies a hashtag event this
event is now supported by all modern
browsers
and the list of browsers is internet
explorer 8.
there are not libraries that support
this firefox 3.6
chrome 5 and if i'm not mistaken
they are about to reach version 100
safari 5
which is very old
and opera 10
and these two
key points are very important here
because the house changed event is
almost not used at all
we don't need to use it we have other
things to use and when we check the list
of modern browsers
we see that we are very far away
and we are not so far away
when we check the the date it's 2009
is march 2009
on march was
the month in which internet explorer 8
replaced officially internet explorer 7.
so there was the version 8 but it was
not distributed with windows
and if you ask what was the original
question
well the original question said how do
you react to hash change in the url
and effectively has changed is an answer
that most developers would like would
answer nowadays
but to think
that 12 years back we were already
fighting browsers to make them work
and begging them
praying so that
people would change their browser so
that we can use new apis and this is
something that existed 12 years ago but
when we think about today a house change
we don't even ask if
it this is supported by the browser when
we develop an application
because we know that every browser
supports them
and this is something that gives me hope
that there is a hope for change for the
better and that the change comes earlier
than anticipated
and i would like to go one year back
at that time the only way to make a
single page application is using
a hash based
routing which gives us a new a url based
with a hash
and
you can use frameworks such as mootools
which is the system that was at the time
that managed those interactions
and that was then nowadays
we can use a routing based in hash but
we can use
routing based in apis
and we can use as well
a lot of frameworks such as router react
router angular
that's the blue icon there
and a lot of routers
and they allow us to have a url that
looks like a classic url and it gives
you full control
but if we think about 2008 that was not
possible
you had to use the hash
and nowadays
the only way to
make that change was on a hash change
but at that time
internet explorer was not what was
considered
a browser
but
at that time it was the default browser
everyone thought of it as a browser
so if we look at the user distribution
in all network all browsers in 2008
the only version of internet explorer
that supported the house change was
internet explorer 8 6 and 7 did not
support this and i would like to think
for a moment
what was the percentage of users in 2018
eight that was using internet explorer
eight
and perhaps you would think that
is one percent but it is not even
zero 0.5
the most impressive thing is that
internet explorer 6 and 7 together were
of internet users
so 7 out of 10 users
were using a browser that did not
support the hash change
so you wondered how mood tools could
support that
how modules could do this for their
users and the answer well you you
wouldn't like it
but there was a technique called poly
which executed run some code
after a few seconds to recover a value
so the code that is showing in your
screen was the same
is a set interval of 2
200 milliseconds
that is going to look at location.hash
compared with the version that you have
stored in the variable
and if it change it will generate some
browsing from our site so that
everything is up to date as it should be
and maybe
you would think that this is outrageous
this code
but i will tell you
i am not exaggerating
you can check the old code in mootools
you can check the comments and you will
see this little piece of code with some
bit more but you will check a set
interval with a very short
time interval
and nowadays hashchange exists
everywhere in all browsers but we don't
even have to use it in a routing code
so this is something that i have
experienced and i would like to talk to
you about the past the present and the
future of front-end routing
so well i've told you about the past and
it's not most interesting thing but it's
fun to talk about
and before talking about what
comes next i would like to talk to you
about the concept of a router
that's the piece of code that you use
between
the url that gives us access to an api
so that we can read or write
but really the router can be divided in
sub modules
which can be more complex
for example most routers are based on a
module called history that's a module
that must interact with the url and why
does this module exist
because not all browsers are going to
equally manage
this history
but it's not only that we also have a
matcher
which extracts the parameters in the url
to parse some part of the url
after adding these url patterns in regex
and etc
and depending on what we're using in the
front end we are using also components
for example link view
in the case of react and i am not going
to talk about components because it's
not that specific but the part of
history and matter this is something we
can talk about today
and we're going to talk about what will
come in the future in javascript
so the history of api
is something that exists in every
browser
it exists everywhere except in internet
explorer 9 but nobody uses it nowadays
even
other versions
supported
and consists in two methods one event
and a few properties
we have this global object history with
two functions that in the same form
one is called push state and the second
is replace state the first argument we
can keep in history and the second
argument is called title and you can
ignore it because it's useless
and the third
is the variable that we have to change
and as you can see
this is problematic
we have not used two functions that use
the same
and have a different parameters instead
of two functions so that's wrong and we
also have an event uh pop states that
instead of being attached to the object
history it's attached to the object
window and we don't know why and we also
have the state of history that's the
data object that we can push
and the length that we
that gives us the number of entries that
there are in the history and we can no
longer not inspect anything else
and to recap very fast how does it work
so we start in movies.com
and if we look at the history that state
is no we just enter the page and the
history length is one
if we
do a push state
in the second argument we just have an
empty string because it doesn't do
anything
the url is going to change
and it is going to increase the length
to 2 and if we do a second push with
another state and another url the url is
going to change
the state is going to change the length
is going to change
and we can also go back
with the browser button which is going
to change the url
because
everybody will experience that this is
what we do in every application every
website and the status will change
but the history length will be the same
because we have three entries in history
but besides that we can't inspect
anything
we can just look at the status in the
history in the current history but not
the next or the one in the back and we
can go forward
in the url is going to change again
but the history length will remain the
same
and the problem of this api is going
further
than what we can do with it
this is a point of design in the api
the way in which we interact with the
url exists from a long time ago
the url is divided in several sections
we have the path
or the path name we have the query or
the search
and we have the hash
or the fragment
and
the gray part which i do not talk about
is the domain
and that is the premium part of the url
because it is the only one that you have
to pay to change but all the rest you
can change
everything else you can change
and you can read and change
from the same property which is the
location that is a global object that
gives us access to a path name
to search
and gives us access to search
that will give us that
interrogation point
that genre horror page one and the hash
that that is the
hashtag reference and that you can
access as a single string of characters
but not only you can read them
using location.pathname
or location.search or href you can also
write them you can also change them
and when they are changed
we are going to create some navigation
we are going to click
in a link
and this is no longer possible with the
push state
because we will need to use it so that
this stays on the same page so this new
api exists from a long time ago history
api
but this limits us
the way we we use javascript it has a
use
that is absolutely correct
before this api it is no longer
considered correct in cpa which is
problematic
but that's not the only problem because
if we have a link a regular link with
aref we can't use it because clicking is
going to reload the page
so depending on what we're using we
would use a link a router link or
whatever
which is going to
call the push state or whatever
and we this is a little bit problematic
because we do not only lose that way of
navigating that exists from a long time
ago but we also lose the native
functions in the browser for example the
scroll behavior
which is going to
find the page at some level if we go
forward or go back and all of that is
lost and the routers have to
re-implement that feature so that it
works
and this
gives us the present of the routing
history api is the only good choice
there is and it is very strange that a
person has had no a problem using it
but this should change with the new api
which is the app history api this is a
proposal
this is something that is not
implemented by any browser yet
but the
the point is that we would like to
correct all these problems that already
exist with history api
and to add a lot of improvements to
routers
not only for
developers but to users
and consists in the function navigate
which is the combination of this push
there is no longer this argument title
that is useless we have state
info and replace info is a new property
would be like a transient state
and we have an event
several events we have this navigate
that's the equivalent of pop state that
is added to app history and this event
is going to be a lot more flexible
which
finally
takes away the problem of the well pop
state is not in in internet explorer is
not going to be executed in a hashtag or
in a manual change of the url which is
not consistent in browsers
and that's impossible to do
it's impossible to manage all the use
cases that there are
and
more interestingly
the history is going to give us access
not only to the state of an entry
but to all entries
and to a lot of features that a lot of
functions that will let us access and
change the state
so we are going to begin entering in
this api we will begin with the function
navigate this is
this looks like changing the href from
location more than a push name
because this function what it does is to
completely navigate it's going to use
change the state and everything but
if we use
an url any url it is going to go to that
url
so it runs a full browsing and it looks
more like a location href
so in a push state you can change the
domain this has advantages because it's
going to scroll
the hash the fragments which
push name doesn't do
and you can go to cross document to
another domain it returns a promise and
we will see about that later
but you can see when the navigation has
ended and that allows the browser to
update the
the bar the loading bar
so the interface of the browser is going
to be better a better experience for the
user that looks more like classic
application when you send a request to a
server
but without having to reload the page
completely
so those are the advantage
of the
of this
and it updates the url immediately
this may look stupid but
not every browser
update the url
in the same way when we do a push state
and this may look
silly
but from the point of view of a router
to be able to provide an experience an
ideal experience to any browser in any
user
this complicates stuff for us a bit
but this is also reversible
which means that it's very easy to
cancel or revert navigation after it has
occurred and i am going to explain this
later
let's see a practical example of this
for example
we will go to a projects url
we can
see a state here which is a list of
projects i would recommend
that the state and the history
and also we have that state that has to
do with the browser for example here
there is something that we can do and
then we can have that information
in the model service and again if the
person says that they don't want to
navigate well that's it so
i
have
just
changed location. what but what is
important is
at event listener with this we can
access with a lot of information
what is important is
that
this is happening
not only with that history point
navigate but also with past name query
and even though with a click in a link
and with that we have access
uh well let's see i will focus only in
one of five of them
uh the
the one that can allow us to cancel
transmission while that allowed us to
have this promise and
to the browser and to define the time of
this navigation
to recovery data also we have
destination
also the information that i already
explained and one sign-up let's see an
example of this
if we want for example to cancel any
browser in any document we can check in
the
event.destination same document and then
if we do a navigate we can
recover
this promise and with this promise
when we have this event
we can know this error
however if we use a transmission while
we can go to any promise and in that way
this will be resolved and then we can
have anything but what is important here
in these both cases is
that it doesn't matter what happened as
a problem if it's a result or it fails
but
just when we call navigate this url is
there and this is very consistent
and this is very useful this also means
that if the browser does not happen if
there's some error
if there is a failure we have a catch in
this promise
but location
also will help but it's very easy to
change
let's
look and current
or real example
well when we recover the information and
then our router extracts
the page and then the the new one
and then the browser is there and once
everything is working
we stop that the browser will stop doing
the spinner and everything will work out
we can change this code if we want it
with
a synchronous function
ef
asynchronous
so if we do all this
any browser
with a link location
or dot navigate
we will have this path
and what is interesting is we we can
have this event dot signal
and if the browser is
canceled for any reason this will be
console 2.
then the browser will
cancel by itself but also we can have
this global effect for example catch an
event the other one it was a
inside navigation outside navigation
and an error
and also
we can have
several listeners
and with this we can add to each event
several promises it can be different and
all these promises can be
combined in a just one transition
with all this
code and we can have a more flexible
access
with a a combination of all the promises
that
has been added by the router but also
for the file for example if we have
several routers with this it's very easy
with a to a developer to add their own
transition while
with an event of navigate
and a writer because it will be
depending with this api
this can
have this promise can be integrated in
this browser
and this transition has more information
has the
the class or the type navigation type
with a back indirect relation also the
the front
and
we have the finish
is
a little bit a sketching in
and navigate success that we already
seen and this very important or
interesting
function options and i love this because
we can say
app history.transition.rollback
and that's it we are in the other page
without any problem
to implement this day by date from the
point of view of a router it's not so
evident it's not work like uh not work
in every cases
to have a function to allow those to do
this directly is an incredible
characteristic
also each entry
in the front each history entry has a
couple of information not only event
target
some other events that
are i think they are pretty interesting
but also we have a key id url index and
same document
and i want to highlight or to focus in
the key and id this property both of
them are uids that are created by the
browser and they are
they differentiate in something very
concrete the first one is the state of
the entry is like an id
like a hash
of the snapshot
we authorize the state of the entry
however the key is specific to the entry
in si
is like a pointer a very concrete
pointer to the entry in the history and
will never change will be the same this
means that we have this api that can we
can go to any and enter
anytime anywhere
and
currently is
the only api that exists is history dot
go
in this function
and has this parameter or this delta
positive or negative
and then is one two
entries in the back or in the front
and this means that we need
that in the router or the user code
there are some routers
we need
to save in some way
the position of each entry and to
calculate at any moment how we are going
forward
how
how many entries we need to go
back or
to the front
but the problem is this this api doesn't
work like that because there are some
relations that we cannot detect
we need to connect and say there is a
browser and i know that my delta is a
plus one minus one
there are other browsers
they're going they're not allowing us
this browser and we need to add one more
and
i would like to show you a very
practical example why this api is pretty
interesting so let's imagine that this
a parallel world
where you can
go back
there is a bad news and a good news in
this parallel world so for example
the kovi to
kovitt 19th is
still existing but the other the good
one there is no history that
but you know that the covet is going to
happen in 2020 and you say well
i would like to be like a nomad in 2018
so in 2019 nine i will be in a very
quiet and peaceful place while this is
happening
and
as a nomad you start
looking or searching or a place
there you can do kayak
and also
you go to different
cities
through america
or through europe or
africa and you are looking for several
cities
and you look check out your budget
maybe beijing
or maybe indonesia vietnam
and then you say no this is too
expensive i will change and i go back
and if you want to see
in the middle of that browser or that
navigation
in hindi indonesia
probably
if you want to do that
today or i don't know in that back
key
when i use it most of the time
i lose the
the information
maybe the prices are higher
due to the cookies
so if i'm doing like a reservation or a
booking it's different but with this
it's so easy to implement it and from
the browser point of view is just a
wrote back to the entry that is linked
what you were looking and then you have
this
you can do a click and in each click
there is a
history dot go to
and you will not lose the history
so there's no reason to not implement it
so there are sometimes that
if this
maybe there are some web pages
it's kind of hard doing it
to have this very good history so you
can go back without losing the state of
the form or what you were doing
so
these
entries in target
we can
have this the navigation
we also can inspect any entry in the
history and it's because the app history
concentrates in the page that we are in
so this means that
this is not going to
can be observed
with a navigator and this is useful
because we are not
we we
currently we have some problems doing
this but every entry of history
in sorry in the in yes in the history is
an end target
and we can listen
we can put a listener
when we go from that
entry to the another one and this is
with the navigator.from so that means
that when we are there and we have a
link or backward or forward and we or we
go to another page
it will be a do this execution this
listener so in this case
we can update that state
and we can
save the cache
and we can reuse that cache and show
all the results
even if we do a new request
and all of this we know that
is a front end is there so
any framework can implement it
but navigate in front is not only the
event we have uh navigate to
and we have finished it result and it's
kind of more complicated is when you
don't use an entry
for example if you go backwards to the
history and then we have that browser or
navigation
we we cannot access anymore but
there are complex cases so what is
interesting is
navigate from n2
and also with navigation guards
the transition while it can be like any
router for example
navigate front and navigate to is like a
navigation guard but very specific
to an entry in the history it's not like
url or a route is very specific
to um just here in this page with this
result with this status
and if we summarize this api history api
for the authors
it's very consistent predictable and
extensible
and without workarounds
it's not the case like push state
and an example well it's more like a
story
if
if we have a push state or replace it in
times
in a very short period of time this will
fail
and why this is a problem because
if you have if you do this and you've
navigate very fast you don't want that
that the speed will be the same
and if there are more than 100 in a very
short time
you will not have this navigation
function
so this is theory
but for developers routers are
lighter
there are less bugs there is a better
integration with micro front ends and
they are extensible but this possibility
is the consistency of the api
with these extensibles this allowed
you to have a micro front ends and to
share to be more integrated or better
integrated so
today these
rotors
is kind of delicate
and
not too coalition
so when
for when can we have this api
well there's no date
i don't think
there is like a
hope for to have a specific date but
what is true that we have
we are waiting for the feedback
also
uh uh already we have a experimental
polyfill
with this real navigation
and it can be fun and i think
uh
they if it
cannot support all the cases of history
because there are some parts of the api
that cannot be used with this
but this is something
this
important and potent part is
is there
and as i told you this is an
experimental polyfill
so maybe your quest next question is all
this is very good but i want to use
something
so today what you can use is this one
history api i already
explain it but we have
another apis orl pattern url and url
search
params these two in specific allowed us
to
to have this new url to change it but
respecting the code the problem is that
recently
that was not used because they are not
well supported
so this means not not all the browsers
can use it and you can imagine the ones
safari for example they have encoding
errors in some apis and internet
explorer directly well never implemented
not doesn't exist
so if you want to use those apis that
are very useful
with with internet explorer you need a
polyfill exists but
and some advantages of this api are the
encoding
this topic is not so complicated there
are some characters that you can have in
the url and others that you can't have
it
so if you want to
write like these it's a very particular
writing and they are very precise ways
for example there are some that you
cannot print it there are others that
are not ascii and the percentage
character
is the same with encoding but what is
funny is every part of the url
has a specific rules in hash
it like this one
in path also you need to hash
the question mark using by the query and
the poly raises
was received just in case and in the
query part you have the same but if you
take out this you write the hash and
those symbols and that's for the query
and all these
that if we compare the browsers
the location dot hash
and this is not correct we will have a
very particular result in safari we have
this url with this space in firefox we
can we the result is hash
is very good
and the url you can read it is perfect
for the user but in chrome is codified
it's not okay but the url some things
work another or not and internet
explorer is
very similar
and then if we have it
in a correct version with a query
we have in safari
this is normal and the url it looks like
this firefox
the same behavior as the other
and the chrome
is the same
and internet explorer is the same we
will have this resort so the behavior in
safari well we can think about it
is kind of weird
in firefox and
chrome they behave a perfect
and internet explorer is the same for
for it
there are some things that are not
updated so ideally this behavior in
firefox and chrome is the one that we
can see in the browsers
and
also we have another api that is
interesting and this can we can use it
use it and i want to talk about this
maybe you've seen this
in some express examples and
others and particularly i want to
highlight the users
and
two points name
and this
is as a pattern or pattern that much
and this means
we have an object that is able or
to match any type of url for example
user slash jackie that this
section before users can be customized
and this will work any other thing
how does this work
this behavior
works
changing or transforming this is strings
in this other example home will become
home
that name is a regular group expression
that anything that is not to slash
and then
if we have a regular expression
customize regular expression
it would be that specific character
several times
but when we use a matcher in this way
and then we have this root so the router
need to check out this route in the same
order
so we go to the usa research versus home
then the next one and say this is work
this is working
but what we wanted was the last one so
how do we resolve this problem there are
several ways to do it
nowadays and
to associate a punctuation to any route
the highest is in the list is the first
one if we use this type of score
users research will be the first one
i don't know what do i have mob movies
new but this will be the first one to
have this match
in this list
all of these exist nowadays thank you to
this url pattern that this allowed us to
add pattern in all the section of the
url so right now i was
reviewing the
path the hash the query
and then we can use it as something like
exec
with this code and then we can see in
the match the different groups that we
already have
we have an input
[Music]
is the path name and then groups with
different names
and if we accept you to
execute with this other route we will
have this exec but what is good of this
or
this is already implemented in chrome
ngn
it working
is not implemented in firefox in or
safari
i do not recommend it but
if we
say well if we remember what what i said
at the beginning of my chat this gave me
hope
with these all these new possibilities
or
we can implement it sooner or later
and with this i hope that you learned
something with this presentation
about the routing of front end and what
is expecting us in the future
and to know how to be an author of the
library thank you